Le grand cachalot est le prétendant idéal
au titre de champion de l'apnée.
C'est tout simplement le plus grand
prédateur à dents de notre planète
et il se nourrit essentiellement
dans les profondeurs de calmars abyssaux
pour alimenter son corps, pouvant peser près
de 45 tonnes et atteindre près de 20 mètres,
il en consomme près de 500 kilos
quotidiennement.
On ne connaissait l'animal que par ses
échouage et ses courts passages en surface.
Pourtant, il passe plus de la moitié de
ses journées dans le monde glacé
et sans lumière,
des grandes profondeurs.
Pour se repérer dans l'obscurité,
le cachalot, comme tous les cétacés à dent,
n'utilise pas ses yeux,
mais un système de radar naturel.
On dit qu'il écholocalise.
Par des soufflets nasaux,
il émet des clics dont il reçoit l'écho
par la mâchoire inférieure.
Même dans le noir total,
son vaste cerveau est ainsi renseigné
sur les formes des canyons,
et la présence de proies.
Jamais personne ne l'avait surpris
dans les abysses,
les couches profondes de l'océan
où la lumière ne pénètre jamais.
Jusqu'en avril 2015,
dans le golfe du Mexique,
quand une équipe de scientifiques
et le robot télécommandé Hercule
ont fait une rencontre extraordinaire
par 600 mètres de profondeur.
Ce rendez-vous abyssal était imprévu.
Un simple fruit du hasard,
survenu quand les scientifiques cherchaient
à cartographier les fonds marins.
Mais il apporte la première preuve visuelle
que le cachalot peut nager à 600 mètres.
Le cachalot peut plonger jusqu'à 2 h.
Comment fait-il ?
Son anatomie est taillée
pour les longues apnées.
À chaque respiration,
le cachalot est capable de renouveler 90%
de l'air de ses poumons.
Alors que nous, les humains, n'y
parvenons qu'à 15%.
Autre atout, ses cellules musculaires
sont particulièrement riches en protéines
porteuses d'oxygène.
Elles en contiennent 10 fois plus
que les nôtres.
Mais ce n'est pas suffisant,
pour économiser ce précieux oxygène
lors des plongées,
le cachalot doit aussi ralentir
son métabolisme et concentrer son sang
dans ses organes vitaux,
son cœur et son cerveau.
Et pour résister à la pression,
comment fait-il ?
Là où nos côtes perforeraient nos poumons,
la cage thoracique du cachalot
est, au contraire, flexible.
Enfin, pour l'aider à plonger,
le cachalot a encore un outil précieux.
Son énorme crâne, qui occupe près d'un
tiers de son corps,
abrite une réserve de graisse,
appelée : spermaceti.
En plongeant, le cachalot coupe
l'arrivée de sang à cette graisse
qui refroidit et se solidifie.
Cette masse agit alors comme une gueuse
qui l'entraîne vers les profondeurs.
En remontant, le cachalot à l'inverse,
réchauffe sa réserve de spermaceti,
qui devient huileuse,
donc plus légère que l'eau.
Et pour éviter les accidents
de décompression,
des réseaux admirables lui permettent
d'éliminer les bulles d'air
tout en amenant l'oxygène au cerveau.
Le cachalot peut ainsi rester immergé
pendant 1h30.
Mais les profondeurs maximales atteintes
lors de ses apnées,
restent encore sujettes à controverse.
Pour les connaître,
il faut aussi les équiper de balises.
Mais comme les cachalots renouvellent
leur peau continuellement,
les balises à ventouses, comme lesdits tags,
ne parviennent pas à adhérer.
Dans l'océan Indien,
au large de l'île Maurice,
les scientifiques de l'association Moby Dick,
guettent les apparitions de cachalots.
Leur méthode, ancrer des balises émettrices,
sur le dos de cachalot,
en doublant ses marquages d'une biopsie,
un petit prélèvement de chair.
Ils pourront ainsi identifier
chaque porteur de balise par son ADN.
Pour une étude exhaustive, ils devront
baliser et identifier plusieurs cachalots.
Par chance, les eaux calmes et profondes
qui ceinturent l'île,
sont devenues un lieu de rassemblement
de troupeaux entiers de cachalots.
Ainsi, en couplant les données géographiques
avec les données bâties métriques,
ils peuvent évaluer les profondeurs maximales
des plongées de chaque animal.
Pour poser leurs balises,
les scientifiques cherchent à exploiter
un point faible du cachalot,
bien connu par les baleiniers.
Un champ de vision limité,
en particulier sur l'arrière.
La raison est simple, les yeux d'un cachalot
ne peuvent pivoter dans leur orbite.
Ainsi, il ne détecte pas le bateau
qui vient par l'arrière,
ce qui permet aux scientifiques
de marquer un premier cachalot.
Problème, désormais, les autres cachalots
sont devenus méfiants.
Une guerre tactique s'engage.
Ces balises posées sur 6 cachalots
ont fonctionnées entre 20 et 48 jours.
Elles ont révélé que certains animaux
séjournaient et plongeaient
dans la zone des 1300 mètres.
Les études en cours
cherchent à prouver que les mâles
regagnent des eaux plus froides
vers le sud.
Notamment en direction des
îles Crozet.
Le pays des Albatros.
Et des tempêtes perpétuelles
surnommées : les 40ᵉ rugissants.
Plusieurs milliers de mètres séparent
ces montagnes liquides, du plancher abyssal.
On ne trouve que des mâles
à ces latitudes.
Dans ce no man's land,
ils semblent attirés par des navires usines
qui s'aventurent plusieurs mois en haute mer.
Ces groupes de mâles,
attendent que ces navires déploient
des kilomètres de lignes,
appelées : palangre.
À la remontée, elles sont garnies d'une
ressource prisée sur les marchés asiatiques,
un poisson des grands fonds,
la Légine.
À l'âge adulte, ce poisson vit
dans des profondeurs
comprises entre 800
et près de 4000 mètres.
Les pêcheurs soupçonnent les cachalots,
de venir dérober leurs poissons
sur leurs lignes, posées entre 800
et 2200 mètres de profondeur.
Les marins chiliens, ont conçu une
protection à base de chaussettes en filets.
Malgré ça, les cachalots parviennent encore
à subtiliser les poissons.
Les pêcheurs de légines,
estiment qu'ils perdent jusqu'à 30%
de leur prise, au profit des cachalots.
Mais ils n'ont jamais pu les prendre
en flagrant délit.
- Maudits cachalots.
Le problème est mondial.
Pour en avoir le cœur net,
des pêcheurs français collaborent
avec le scientifique Gaétan Richard,
qui embarque pour une marée de 3 mois,
au large des îles Crozet.
- En utilisant les palangre comme support,
on va pouvoir déployer des dispositifs
acoustiques, comme celui-ci,
on a un enregistreur, et 2 hydrophones.
Ce dispositif va enregistrer
les sons émis par les cachalots.
Ce qui nous intéresse,
c'est les clics d'échocolocation.
Quand l'animal va produire un clic,
il va arriver sur notre dispositif
et notamment sur un hydrophone,
puis sur l'autre.
Connaissant la distance, et sachant à
quelle vitesse le son se propage dans l'eau.
On va ensuite pouvoir localiser l'animal
par rapport à notre dispositif.
Les hydrophones de Gaétan et d'autres
céthologues, révèlent de curieuses données.
Bien que les lignes soient déposées entre
800 et 2200 mètres de profondeur,
les cachalots ne plongent jamais très
profondément autour des palangriers.
Mais pourquoi apparaissent-ils
autour du navire,
à partir du moment où les pêcheurs
commencent à remonter leur palangre ?
Pour le savoir,
Gaétan place des accéléromètres
sur les lignes juste avant l'hameçon.
Ces appareils détectent, et enregistrent la
différence de tension sur les filins.
Une grande tension pourrait trahir
un larcin de cachalot.
En couplant les données des accéléromètres
et des hydrophones,
on parvient à reconstituer
le mode opératoire du cachalot.
En prédateur opportuniste,
il économise son énergie
et plonge le moins profondément possible.
À la remontée, il saisit la ligne mère
de la palangre entre ses 2 mâchoires
et glisse lentement le long de la ligne,
pour décrocher les poissons qu'il viendra
cueillir quand il dérive entre 2 eaux.
Il ne s'aventure sur le plancher abyssal,
que pour manger sur les lignes
déposées à moindre profondeur.
Il est alors capable de planter sa mâchoire
dans la vase, pour décrocher les légines.
Curieusement, il dérobe peu les poissons
à moins de 300 mètres de profondeur.
Pour une bonne raison,
près de la surface, il subit la concurrence
d'un redoutable prédateur, l'orque.
- Maudites Orques.
Jared Towers a planté
un enregistreur de plongée
dans le lard d'un grand mal cachalot,
et confirmé ses extraordinaires
capacités de plongeur en apnée.
Pendant 17 jours d'enregistrement,
ce concentré de technologie a révélé
que le cachalot a séjourné 8 jours
près d'un palangrier,
pour effectuer des plongées
d'une vingtaine de minutes
à quelques centaines de mètres
de profondeur.
Puis, il s'est éloigné
et a chassé par lui-même.
Ses apnées l'ont entraîné
jusqu'à 1500 mètres de profondeur.
Mieux. 6 mois plus tard, en Norvège,
l'équipe de Natacha Aguilar
a placée desdits tags spécialement conçus
pour s'agripper sur les cachalots.
Leurs plongées les ont entraînés
jusqu'à 1862 mètres.
Le record à ce jour.
Pendant que vous regardez ce film,
un cachalot retient sa respiration
et chasse le calmar géant,
à près de 2 kilomètres sous la surface.